the story of an assonance Akari
radcliffe and her release for from
israelian Iranian prison and we
understand this morning it may be tied
up with a 400 million pound debt owed by
the UK government to Iran reports in The
Guardian newspaper today and say that
the Ministry of Defence has rejected a
request from the Foreign Office to pay
up this money which is for a 30 year old
British tank sale they say that they're
not prepared to hand over the money to
the Iranian Revolutionary Guard Corps
and this route may be stalling Nath
earnings release well let's get now the
thoughts of nazan Eve's husband Richard
Radcliffe and he joins us from
Westminster good morning to you Richard
good morning now it sounds like this
round between two government departments
over money owed to Iran has been
bubbling behind the scenes for some time
it's now out in the public domain when
did you first hear about it and what was
your reaction to its link to nothing
that's right so so you're right there's
there's been a secret court case in
London between Iran and the UK and it's
in fact between a British a Modi company
and Iran over a debt that the UK owes to
Iran and it's been going on for a long
long time so we knew of the existence of
the court case The Sunday Times of the
weekend got access to court papers so
they reported about it and then this
would have follow on ever since and
obviously it's something that we've been
writing letters to different ministers
over the time calling for you know the
government's are sort of well mainly
become clean and explained what was
going on and what the holdup was my it's
the first I'd heard of it was in The
Guardian that was a dispute between the
mmm I do in the Foreign Office I'm have
to say my experience is that all bits of
government are fairly guarded on the
subject yeah it must be a huge
frustration for you because this is a
debt that dates back some 30 years and
it seems that the government departments
are thinking if they hand over this cash
essentially what they'll be doing is
handing over a ransom Vernazza mean that
seems to be the the overriding feeling
at the moment is that your understanding
of the situation I mean might you
legally of course the arguments nonsense
so you can't say listen we don't want to
give the money to the Central Bank of
Iran because they've got some dodgy
friends so they'll give it to illegal
debt as a legal debt so I think it would
our understanding is that there is
level of secrecy of an honest and
openness around quite what's going on a
why it won't be paid that different
reasons given a different points and
it's been related to sanctions at some
times now being related to concerns
about the Revolutionary Guard and there
is a way in which of course this has
been going on a long time and as it's
gone on a long time you know court was
tried and now people have been held and
there is a complexity as to how the
government handles what Iran has which
is hostage diplomacy and that said I
think the governor's got two obligations
one is to protect its citizens that are
currently going through this and nothing
is not the only one and then also to
protect for the long term I'm not sure
keeping it all secret has been the way
forwards yeah you say complex you also
mentioned secretive how much you being
kept up to date with the government's
progress in try to secure NASA news
release um so we we obviously have
regular meetings with the Foreign Office
you know periodically we'll meet with
the foreign secretary and how well
they're there I'm sorting out the
underlying issues been more guarded
about sharing that and and obviously
that plays through that we have our
frustrations and I've been on on skype
before complaining at different points
about the government and obviously knows
me in sitting in the prison cell gets I
mean very down because you know
fundamentally this is this is nothing to
do with us this is a fight between two
governments we should have no business
being connected to it yeah and nothing
sitting in a Cell is that the
government's thrush out how is she do
you know have you ever spoken to her
recently I spoke to Ron on Monday yeah
low I think it's fair to say if for us
we live for a sort of milestone to
milestone so that the next one coming up
is is Gabriel's birthday
it's when she turns five and that's
needed asked her at the last family
visit um you know what did she wants to
for a birthday where does she want to
have a birthday party and blessed she
said all she thought about it said well
I'd like to have imprisoned mummy so
that you can be there which was
obviously very tough and hasn't into
here